Glutathione is okay to take if one has hormone-positive breast cancer.
One of the well-known Lyme doctors recommends glutathione, high dose, and alkycels are
gold.
Her herxides really, what are your thoughts on this?
Well if you didn't have cancer, glutathione is a great thing to take for anybody with autoimmune
disease.
So now I don't have a cancer diagnosis, but I have autoimmune disease or stage 3 Lyme,
it's glutathione, a good thing to take, absolutely.
So I would totally agree with that doctor, but cancer throws a whole lot of the thing
in it.
So you're going to take glutathione with cancer, you're at risk of keeping cancer cells alive.
So personally I would not do that with cancer.
Now if you were in full remission and your cancer wasn't active, then by all means you
could throw up that advice.
But if your cancer is active and you're dealing with trying to kill cancer, I would not use
glutathione.